This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This episode explores explicit themes. If you're listening with small kids, you may want to save this for later. Parties were huge, hookups were huge. Everyone just seemed to be doing everything with each other. And yet I always kind of felt like I wasn't doing it right. There are certain ideas that send the media into a panic. One of them is hook-up culture.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。本集探讨的是成年人题材的内容。如果您正与幼小的孩子一同收听，建议您稍后再听。派对规模很大，乱搞也很普遍。每个人似乎都在和所有人发生关系。然而，我总是觉得自己好像没有做对。有些观念会让媒体陷入恐慌。其中之一就是乱搞文化。
College students are quote unquote, hooking up. Hook-up, hook-up. Hook-up. Hook-up culture. Yeah, I wonder where people can just be sitting in a cafe and find someone to hook up with. Are you buying this? Kids are more sexual than ever.
大学生们正在“乱搞”。乱搞，乱搞。乱搞。乱搞文化。是的，我很好奇人们怎么能随便坐在咖啡馆里，就能找到人乱搞。你相信这个吗？现在的年轻人比以往任何时候都更具有性开放性。
Stories about casual sex on college campuses have long been a staple of cable news, but the truth is more nuanced. College students are actually not having more sex than their parents did a generation ago, but something has changed. Not just in what students do or what they don't do, but in how they think. I have students who have had sex many times drunk, but have never held someone's hand. If casual sex was taboo a generation ago, emotional intimacy has become taboo today. It's something to be explored in secret. Maybe even something to be ashamed about. I think it feels bad to be used, but I think the alternative is that nobody wants to use you and I think
关于大学校园里临时性行为的故事长期以来一直是电视新闻的常态，但事实要复杂得多。事实上，大学生发生的性行为并没有比他们的父母那一代人多，但有些事情确实变了。不仅仅是学生们的行为发生了变化，他们的思想也在改变。我有些学生曾多次在醉酒状态下发生性行为，却从未牵过别人的手。如果说在一代人以前，临时性行为是一种禁忌，那么今天，情感亲密反而成了禁忌。这是一件需要秘密探索的事。甚至可能是一件令人感到羞耻的事。我认为被人利用感觉很糟糕，但我认为替代方案是没人愿意利用你，而且我认为
that that's worse. Lisa Wade is a sociologist at Occidental College. In her book, American Hookup, the new culture of sex on campus, Lisa interviews college students and finds that hookup culture has a complex set of social rules. She says these rules threaten the emotional well-being of students, those who embrace the culture, and those who want nothing to do with it. Lisa, thanks for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me. We spoke with several students in your book, Lisa, and we're going to hear from them in
那会更糟。丽莎·韦德是西方学院的社会学家。在她的书《美国乱搞：校园性爱新文化》中，丽莎采访了大学生，发现乱搞文化有着一套复杂的社会规则。她说，这些规则威胁到了学生的心理健康，无论是那些拥护这种文化的学生，还是那些对此敬而远之的学生。丽莎，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。丽莎，我们在你的书中采访了几位学生，我们将在接下来的谈话中听到他们的声音。
this conversation. One of the things that kept coming up was that there's no one definition of what hooking up actually is. It can mean a variety of things from making out to having sex, but for all the ambiguity, there does seem to be a clear set of guidelines when it comes to how students should hook up. You know, it's funny because the ideology around hookups is that they're supposed to be spontaneous. And the fact is that there's a pretty rigid set of rules
不断浮现的一个问题是，“乱搞”实际上并没有一个单一的定义。它可以意味着从亲热到发生性关系的各种事情，但尽管存在种种模棱两可之处，在学生应该如何乱搞方面，似乎确实存在一套清晰的准则。你知道，这很有趣，因为关于乱搞的意识形态是它们应该是自发的。但事实是，对于乱搞是如何发生的，存在着一套相当死板的规则。
for how hookups happen. Many of them, probably most of them start at parties where there's drinking. And the way to initiate it is through dancing. So usually in these heterosexual encounters, women will initiate the dancing by going into the middle of the dance floor. And then in a very sort of gender-traditional way, hope that someone picks her and comes up along behind her. Sometimes the woman doesn't even know who is behind her,
其中许多，可能大多数都始于有酒喝的派对。而发起这种行为的方式是通过跳舞。因此，通常在这些异性恋的交往中，女性会通过走到舞池中央来发起跳舞。然后，以一种非常性别传统的方式，希望有人注意到她并走到她身后。有时女性甚至不知道身后是谁，
which creates a conundrum because part of hooking up is trying to hook up with people that your friends approve of and think are like a good catch. And so often she's dancing, someone comes up behind her, and then what she'll do is she'll look across the circle to one of her girlfriends and try to get some indication as to whether or not she should continue. Let's talk some more about this idea that hookups are a way to win the approval of your friends.
这就产生了一个难题，因为乱搞的一部分是试图和你的朋友们赞同的、认为是不错的人乱搞。所以很多时候她在跳舞，有人走到她身后，然后她会做的是，看着圈子里的某个女性朋友，试图得到某种暗示，表明她是否应该继续下去。让我们更多地谈谈“乱搞是赢得朋友认可的一种方式”这个想法。
You're saying that some hookups move you up the social packing order and others move you down? Hookups are decidedly not about finding any sort of romantic connection and suggesting that it should be or that one is doing it for that reason is tantamount to breaking a social rule. They're often not so much about pleasure in particular for women. They're very much about status. So the idea is to be able to brag about or having sort of gotten someone who other people might also wish they could have
你是说有些乱搞会让你在社交阶梯上上升，而另一些则会让你下降？乱搞绝对与寻找任何形式的浪漫关系无关，暗示它应该是或出于这种理由而这样做，就等于违反了社会规则。它们通常与快乐无关，特别是对女性而言。它们很大程度上关乎地位。所以这个想法是能够吹嘘或者得到了一个别人也可能希望能够得到的人，
gotten. So it's all about being able to say I got that guy over there or that person that everyone's looking for, I managed to be the one who hooked up with him tonight. One of the unspoken rules to talk about in hook-up culture is that it's really important that the hook-up be meaningless. One of the young men we spoke with described a situation that almost seems Kafka-esque. We really like each other, but she would not have sex with me. But I also knew that she was working up with someone. And this was such a confusing concept, which is that people will have sex with people that they don't like,
所以这完全在于能够说我得到了那边的那个家伙，或者那个每个人都在寻找的人，我设法成为了今晚和他乱搞的人。在乱搞文化中，一个需要讨论的未言明的规则是，乱搞必须是没有意义的，这一点真的很重要。我们采访过的一个年轻人描述了一种几乎带有一点卡夫卡风格的情况。我们真的很喜欢彼此，但她不会和我发生性关系。但我也知道她一直在和别人乱搞。这是一个非常令人困惑的概念，也就是说人们会和自己不喜欢的人发生性关系，
but won't have sex with people that they do like. And of course, what does young man is saying? He can't understand why this young woman who likes him and that he likes is having sex with someone else whom she doesn't like but won't have sex with him. What the students are confronted with is this artificial binary between careless and careful sex. On the one hand, we have this idea that when we get into romantic relationships, we're supposed to be loving and kind, and the sex that happens
却不会和自己喜欢的人发生性关系。当然，这个年轻人说的是什么？他无法理解为什么这个喜欢他、他也喜欢的年轻女性会和另一个她不喜欢的人发生性关系，却不肯和他发生性关系。展现在学生们面前的是这种漫不经心的性与小心翼翼的性之间的人为二分法。一方面，我们有一种观念，即当我们进入恋爱关系时，我们应该充满爱心和善良，而在这类关系中发生的性行为是非常忠诚的。另一方面，我们有临时性行为的概念，这与前者相反。这意味着，一旦临时性行为摆在桌面上，所有伴随恋爱关系的善意都被认为是违背剧本的。
in those kinds of relationships is very committed. And on the other hand, we have this concept of casual sex, which is the opposite of that. And that means that all of the kindnesses that go along with romantic relationships are considered off-script, once casual sex is on the table. So if two students are going to hook up together and they want it to be meaningless, then they have to do some work to make sure that both they and everyone else understands that we're over in this meaningless camp and not this powerfully meaningful one. And so to sort of
因此，如果两个学生要在一起乱搞，并且希望它是毫无意义的，那么他们必须做一些工作，以确保他们自己和其他所有人都明白，我们是在这个毫无意义的阵营，而不是那个具有强大意义的阵营。因此，为了说服自己和他人，或者向他人展示这一切是毫无意义的，他们必须找到一种表演“毫无意义”的方式。这不是自动发生的。他们通过以下方式做到这一点，例如，确保他们在乱搞时喝醉了，或者显得喝醉了。
convince themselves and other people or to show them tells another people that it was meaningless, they have to find a way to perform meaningless. It's not automatic. And they do that by, for example, making sure that they're drunk, or they appear to be drunk when they hook up. So my students actually speak in pretty hushed tones
所以我的学生实际上是用一种相当低声细语的语气来谈论清醒性行为。清醒性行为是非常严肃的，但如果学生们喝了酒，那么这有助于传达出“这毫无意义”的信息。另一种方法是确保他们不会和同一个人乱搞太多次。所以如果他们真的在浪漫层面上不喜欢这个人，只乱搞一次，最多两次，然后就切断关系。第三件他们为了确立这种无意义性而必须做的事情，是在事后对那个人的生活进行某种降职。
about sober sex. Sober sex is very serious, but if the students have been drinking, then that helps send the message that it's meaningless. Another way is to make sure that they don't hook up with the same person very many times. So if they really don't like the person in a romantic way, just hook up once, maybe twice, and then cut it off. And then the third thing they have to do to try to establish this meaninglessness is to sort of give that person a demotion in their lives afterward.
无意义的概念意味着我们也根本不应该在任何方面关心那个人。你在书中谈到，尽管你知道，校园里到处都在谈论乱搞，但这并不一定反映出实际发生的情况有多少。因此，人们对学生的性活动有很多担忧，但事实证明，从大多数衡量标准来看，他们的活跃程度并不比他们父母在他们那个年纪时更高。
The idea that it's meaningless means that we're also not supposed to care about that person at all, and in any way. You're talking the book about how even though, you know, talk about hookups is ubiquitous on college campuses, that doesn't necessarily reflect how much of it is actually going on. So there's a lot of consternation about students' sexual activity, but it turns out that they are no more sexually
平均每个毕业的大四学生在四年里乱搞过八次。也就是说每个学期一次，其中有一半的乱搞对象是他们以前乱搞过的人。事实上，大约三分之一的学生在整个大学生涯中甚至连一次乱搞都没有。但这并不意味着他们没有被这些关于他们应该做什么的强有力的观念所包围。这并不意味着他们能改变
active by most measures than their parents were at their age. The average graduating senior has hooked up eight times in four years. So that's once a semester, and half of those hookups are with someone that they've hooked up with before. And in fact, about a third of students won't hook up even a single time their entire college career. But that doesn't mean that they're not surrounded by these really powerful ideas about what they should be doing. And it doesn't mean that they can change
同龄人与他们互动的方式，或者高等教育运作的方式。因此，尽管校园乱搞文化实际上可能得到了少数狂热分子的支持，但你提出的观点之一是，这些人通常来自在社会中历来拥有巨大权力和特权的群体。大约15%的学生真正、真正、真正喜欢乱搞文化。它带给了他们大学生活正好想要的东西。研究表明，如果你问那些学生——他们是乱搞最多的学生——如果你问他们过得开心吗，
how their peers interact with them or the way in which higher education works. So even though campus hook-up culture might actually be something that is endorsed by a relatively small number of people who are enthusiasts, one of the points you make is that these are people who often come from groups who have traditionally had a lot of power and privilege in society. About 15% of students really, really truly enjoy hook-up culture. It gives them exactly what they want out of college. And studies show that if you ask those students, and they're the students that are hooking up the most, if you ask them if they're having a good time,
他们会说是的，我相信他们。大约三分之一的学生完全选择退出。剩下的学生在中间的某个地方，他们对临时性行为持矛盾态度，但如果你看看那些最喜欢乱搞文化的学生，这些学生绝大多数是异性恋、白人、来自中上阶层或富裕背景、男性、身体健全、
they say yes, and I believe them. About a third of students are completely opted out. The rest of the students are somewhere in the middle, and they're ambivalent about the idea of casual sex, but if you look at the students who enjoy hook-up culture the most, those students are disproportionately going to be heterosexual, white, come from an upper middle class or wealthy background, they're going to be male, they're going to be able-bodied,
传统上具有吸引力。这对于少数族裔或LGBT群体有什么不同呢？少数族裔面临着白人学生所没有的各种复杂问题。这在很大程度上取决于我们正在看的特定交叉点是什么。因此，一些少数族裔比其他人更容易被白人学生接受。所以非裔美国男性和亚裔女性通常被认为是性感和充满异国情调的，而亚裔男性和非裔美国女性则被认为较少具备这些特质。
conventionally attractive. And how is this different for racial minorities or people from the LGBT community? Racial minorities face all kinds of complicated problems that white students don't. And it depends a lot kind of on what particular intersection we're looking at. So some racial minorities are embraced by white students more than others. So African-American men and Asian women are usually considered hot and exotic, whereas Asian men and African-American women are considered less so.
因此，这很大程度上取决于学生所处的种族、性别和阶层的交叉点。但总体而言，由于推力和拉力的原因，我们在少数族裔中看到了较低的乱搞率。所以，部分原因是由于种族主义和特权化白人的情色等级制度，他们被排挤出去了。但他们也往往被拉出去，因为少数族裔更有可能是有宗教信仰的。他们喝更少的酒，为了上大学可能一开始就得表现得无可挑剔。因此，少数族裔在乱搞文化中并不那么受欢迎，他们也觉得这种文化没那么吸引人。
So it very much depends on what intersection of race, gender, and class too, that students are sitting in. But overall, we see lower rates of hooking up among racial minorities for both push and pull reasons. So, part of it is they're pushed out because of racism and an erotic hierarchy that privileges whiteness. But they also tend to get pulled out because racial minorities are more likely to be religious. They drink less alcohol, they maybe had to be more squeaky clean to get into college to begin with. So racial minorities aren't as welcome in hookup culture and they also don't find it as attractive.
那LGBT群体呢？对于那些不认为自己是异性恋的学生——我们实际上仍需要对此进行更多研究——但似乎发生的情况是，在小型校园或人们并不十分出柜的校园里，对于那些不认为自己是异性恋或双性恋的学生来说，并没有一个替代的乱搞场景。并且确实存在的乱搞场景是被极度异性恋化了。在这些情况下，学生们自担风险参与其中，冒着行为或态度上的恐同症的风险，或者他们离开校园。
And what about the LGBT community? For students who don't identify as heterosexual and we actually still need to do more research on this, but what it seems to be happening is that on small campuses or campuses where people aren't very out, there's not an alternative hookup scene for students who don't identify as heterosexual or bisexual. And the hookup scene that does exist is hyper heterosexualized. And in those cases, students participate at their own risk, risking homophobia in either
这就是为什么Grindr打入大学校园的时间比Tinder早得多，因为许多被识别为非异性恋的学生都在使用它来寻找校外的乱搞对象。当我们回来时，我将询问丽莎关于乱搞文化对年轻人情感生活的影响。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。有些人提出了一个论点，其中包括左翼女权主义者和右翼自由主义者，他们认为乱搞可以是解放性的。
behavior or attitude, or they go off campus. And that is why Grindr hit college campuses way earlier than Tinder did because a lot of students who identified as non-heterosexual were using it to find hookups off campus. When we come back, I'm going to ask Lisa about the effects of hookup culture on the emotional lives of young people. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. One argument that some make and this includes feminists on the left and libertarians on the right is that hookups can be liberating.
人们有机会进行实验，尝试新事物，他们被赋予权力去发现自己的偏好。但我们采访过的一位学生丽莎说，有时听起来像是一种赋权的东西，往往会变成别的什么。我确实有过这样的经历：一旦乱搞已经开始，那些期望就会开始显现出来，而且它们的表达并不友善。你知道，这不是，这不是一场对话，比如，嘿，你愿意尝试这个吗？或者，嘿，你知道的，当我的伴侣对我这样做时，我真的很喜欢。它更像是，你现在就要这样做。
People have a chance to experiment, try new things, they're empowered to discover their preferences. But one of the students we spoke with Lisa said that what sometimes starts out sounding like empowerment often becomes something else. I did have experiences where the expectations once the hook-up had already started would start to come out and they wouldn't come out kindly. You know, it's not, it wasn't a conversation of, hey are you willing to try this or hey, you know, I really like it when my partner does this to me. It would be a little bit more of, you're going to do this now.
所以丽莎，乱搞文化与某些人所说的强奸文化有什么关系吗？是的，我认为乱搞文化是一种强奸文化，因为它促成了并原谅了转化为性侵犯的行为。你能详细谈谈吗？我的意思是，有些狂热分子基本上会说，你知道的，我们只是在行使，你知道的，我们的自由选择。我们不受可能阻碍上一代人的规范的束缚，人们进行实验、尝试新事物、弄清楚自己到底是谁，这有什么错？所以我们看到校园里存在乱搞文化的部分原因
So Lisa, does hook up culture have anything to do with what some people would call rape culture? Yes, I would argue that hook up culture is a rape culture in that it facilitates and excuses behaviors that translate into sexual assault. Can you expand on that? I mean, there are enthusiasts who would basically say, you know, we're just exercising, you know, our free choice. We're not constrained by the norms that might have hindered a prior generation, what's wrong with people experimenting, trying new things, figuring out who they really are? So part of the reason we see hookup culture
可以追溯到性革命和女性主义运动。女性主义运动对女性提出了两方面的要求，无论是在性方面还是其他方面。她们希望女性有机会做男性所做的事情，并体现男性的特质和兴趣。她们希望每个人都坐下来注意到，女性一直以来在做的事情以及人们认为她们拥有的特质和兴趣同样是有价值的。而我们实际上只得到了其中的一半。因此，女权主义者成功地说服了美国。
on college campuses can be traced back to the sexual revolution in the women's movement. And the women's movement wanted two things for women, both sexually and otherwise. They wanted women to have the opportunity to do the things that men do and to embody masculine traits and interests. And they wanted everyone to sit up and notice that the things women had been doing all along and the traits and interests
在很大程度上，女性应该被允许做男性所做的事情，甚至拥有男性的特质。但我们从未真正去重视那些我们定义为女性化的东西。因此，一个在今天的美国长大的年轻女性将从
that they were believed to have were also valuable. And we really only got half of that. So the feminists succeeded in convincing America. For the most part, the women should be allowed to do what men do and even have masculine traits. But we never really got around to valuing the things that we define as feminine. So a young woman who's growing up in America today is going to, she's going to be told by
大多数（并非所有父母都这样，但大多数父母会）父母那里得到鼓励，将男性的特质和兴趣融入她的个性中。甚至当她这样做时，父母会鼓励她，并且当她这样做时，可能比她融入女性人格特质时给予更多的奖励。所以当她还是个孩子的时候，她喜欢玩工程玩具，我们会感到兴奋；当她选择运动而不是啦啦队时，我们会感到兴奋；当她决定
most, not all parents are like this, but most parents are going to encourage their daughters to mix in masculine traits and interests into her personality. And they're even going to encourage her to do so, and perhaps reward her more so when she does that than then when she incorporates feminine personality traits. So we're excited when she likes to play with engineering toys when she's a kid, and we're excited when she chooses sports over cheerleading, and we're excited that she decides
主修物理而不是教育时，我们会感到兴奋。因此，女性一直在接受这种信息。如果她们有任何注意的话，就会非常清楚，正如他们所说，“举止温顺的女性很少创造历史”，当我们看到你表现得像我们认为的典型男性时，我们会奖励你，我们认为这太棒了。因此，当她们到达校园时，这就是她们试图做的，我们中的任何人都不应该感到惊讶的是，校园里的许多女性决定以她们被奖励对待生活中其他一切事物相同的方式来对待性。
to major in physics instead of education. And so women have been getting this message. If they're paying any attention at all, it's very clear that, as they say, well-'re paying any attention at all, it's very clear that, as they say, well-behaved women rarely make history, we reward you, we think it's great, when you act like we think a stereotypical man does. So then when they get to campus, that's what they try to do, and it should surprise none of us that many women on campus decide to approach sexuality the same way they've
抱着这种想法：要做的事、被解放的方式就是表现得像我想象中的典型男性那样。所以你知道，虽然有很多人确实说乱搞可以是解放性的，但我们采访过的一位年轻女性说，她实际上觉得自己有点被困住了。我认为女孩在被利用时是知道的，而且我认为被人利用感觉很糟糕，但我认为替代方案是没人愿意利用你，这意味着你没有和任何人乱搞，而且我认为那会更糟。
been rewarded for approaching everything else in their lives. With this idea of the thing to do, the way to be liberated is to act in the way I think a stereotypical man might. So you know, while there are lots of people who do say that hookups can be liberating, one of the young women we spoke with said she actually feels a little trapped. I think girls know when they're being used and I think it feels bad to be used but I think the alternative is that nobody wants to use you and that means that you're not
所以对于那个问题，有一些令人心碎的地方，丽莎，因为听起来这个年轻女性是在说，她意识到自己觉得正在被利用，但她觉得除了被利用别无选择。对于在乱搞文化中并不真正享受临时性行为的女性来说，并没有太多好的选择，虽然确实有一些人享受。但对于其余的人来说，她们基本上面临着两种选择。一种是她们不参与任何性活动，
talking up with anybody and I think that that's worse. So there's something heartbreaking about that question Lisa because it sounds like what this young woman is saying is that she recognizes that she feels she is being used, but she feels she doesn't have a choice but to be used. There are not a lot of good options for women in hook-up culture that don't truly enjoy casual sex, and there are some that do. But for the rest of them, they're kind of faced with two options. One is that they don't participate in any sexual
这也意味着永远不会与任何人建立任何形式的浪漫关系。另一种是与一个人度过这段时期——乱搞时期——怀着希望在另一端出来时能成为那个人的女朋友。校园里的双重标准有些不同。过去，男性拥有把女性归入两种类别之一的权力，即好女孩或坏女孩。如果女性只是，引用原话，“行为端庄”，她大概可以留在好女孩阵营里，尽管这没有保证。但今天，男性仍然拥有把女性归入这些群体之一的权力，但他们基本上把所有女性都归入了坏女孩群体，无论如何，所有与他们乱搞的女性都是如此。
activity at all, which also means never getting into any sort of romantic relationship with someone. And the other is passing through this period with a person, the hook-up period, with the hopes of coming out the other end as that person's girlfriend. And there's something different about the double standard on college campuses. It used to be that men would have the power to kind of put women into one of two categories, the good girl or the bad girl. And if women just, quote unquote, behaved herself, she could probably stay in the good girl camp, although there's no guarantee. But today, men still have this power to put women into one of these groups, but they put basically all women into the bad girl group, all women they're hooking up with anyway.
然后，在某个时候有权决定，哦，我和你乱搞了一段时间，现在我决定我喜欢你，现在我要以尊重和平等的态度对待你。如果一个女性想要一段在某个时候能受到尊重和作为平等对待的关系，那么她必须经历这个她并没有得到这些对待的时期。因此，女性的选择要么是完全退出乱搞文化，要么是将自己置于这样一个时期：她受到不尊重的对待，寄希望于它能在另一端转化为更好的东西。我们采访过的一位女性实际上描述了一种非常类似于这种情况的情况，但也描述了她所面临的一个困境，
And then, have the power at some point to decide, oh I've been hooking up with you for a while, now I'm going to decide that I like you, and now I'm going to treat you with respect and as an equal. If a woman wants a relationship where at some point she'll be retreated with respect and as an equal, then she has to go through this period where she's not those things. So women's options are either opt out of hook-up culture altogether or expose herself to this period where she's treated disrespectfully in the hopes that it translates into something better on the other end. One of the women we talked with actually describes a situation very much like this, but also describes a dilemma which she faced,
也就是即使当她喜欢一个和她乱搞过的人时，乱搞文化的规则也阻止她告诉对方她真正想要的是什么。那种和女孩乱搞却不肯放手的家伙。那并不是人们常谈论的事情。相比之下，那种乱搞一次就疯狂爱上你、对你纠缠不休的女孩。那个疯狂的女孩。是的，那是确有其事的。
which is even when she likes someone that she's hooked up with, the rules of hook-up culture prevent her from telling the other person what she actually wants. That kind of guy that hooks up with a girl and doesn't let go. That's not really a thing people talk about. Versus the girl who hooks up once and just falls in love with you and never leaves you alone. That crazy girl. Yeah, that's a thing.
而我们拼命地不想看起来像那样。所以当你和某个你实际上真的很喜欢、真的很想和他们在一起的人乱搞时，然后他们没有给你回短信。于是就结束了。听起来那是一个糟糕的处境，因为你经历乱搞文化是为了试图找到一段关系，但规则却要求你实际上不能要求得到它。对。对。
And we so desperately don't want to look like that. So when you hook up with someone that you actually really liked, and you really wanted to be with them, and then they don't text you back. And so it's over. That sounds like a terrible place to be in because you are going through hook-up culture to try and find a relationship, but the rules demand that you can't actually ask for one. Yeah. Yeah.
她用了“拼命”这个词，这很有意思。我在书中辩称，如今学生被叫到的最糟糕的事情不是荡妇，甚至也不是保守，尽管这也是个大词。而是绝望。所以如果规则是我们应该进行毫无意义的性行为，并且我们正在上演所有让我们能够维持这种幻觉的事情，即使这并不是人们实际的感受。那么他们说“我其实挺喜欢你的”就违反了规则。这是有性别差异的，对乱搞伴侣不感兴趣，比男性的表态更让人难以置信，即使他们
And she used the word desperately, which was interesting. I argue in the book that the worst thing a student can be called these days isn't slut, and it's not even prude, although that one's big one. It's desperate. So if the rule is that we're supposed to be having meaningless sex, and we're enacting all the things that enable us to keep that illusion going, even when that's not how people actually feel. Then it's against the rules for them to say, I actually quite like you. And this is gendered in that, to be disinterested in a hook-up partner, is less believable than men's, even when they are
在这方面其实相当擅长。因此，男性往往会假设所有女性都对与他们建立关系感兴趣，无论她们是否真的感兴趣，这使得男性在乱搞后比平时更加冷漠，因为他们假设女孩只是想和他们发生关系。这让女性处于一种试图证明自己不是那种想和刚乱搞的家伙在一起的人的境地。因此，她比平时更加冷漠。并且由于规则是比对方表现得更不在乎，这就造成了这种向下盘旋的
actually quite good at this. And so men tend to assume that all women are interested in having a relationship with them, whether they are or not, which makes men even more sort of standoffish after a hookup than they otherwise would be, because they're assuming the girl just wants to get with them. And it puts women in the position of trying to prove that they aren't the kind of person who wants to get with the guy she just hooked up with. And so then she's even more standoffish than she would be otherwise. And because the rule is to care less than the other person, then that creates this downward
螺旋。丽莎，我们刚刚讨论了乱搞文化可能对校园女性服务得不太好，但我从你的书中也感觉到，它可能对男性服务得也不好。确实如此。男人是人，女人也是人，他们有各种各样的不同需求，是乱搞文化无法满足的。
spiral. We've talked a little bit Lisa about how hook up culture might not be serving women very less than the other person, then that creates this downward spiral. We've talked a little bit Lisa about how hook-up culture might not be serving women very well on campus, but I also get the sense from your book that it might not be serving men very well. It's not. Men are human beings, and so are women, and they have all kinds of different needs that are not served by hookup culture.
乱搞文化迎合了男性的刻板印象。有一些男人和女人确实是那样的，他们在那种环境中确实如鱼得水。但大多数学生想要的是不同的机会组合。当你去问时，实际上男性比女性多出几个百分点表示他们希望自己能处于一段恋爱关系中。拥有有意义的关系，拥有善良的有意义的性体验，
Hookup culture serves a stereotypical idea of a man. There are some guys and some women that are like that, that really do thrive in that. But most students want a different mix of opportunities. And when you ask actually men are more likely than women by a few percentage points to say that they wish they could be in a relationship. Having meaningful relationships, having meaningful sexual
那是每个人都想要的，当然不仅仅是女性。所以你在书中写道，乱搞文化要求漫不经心，奖励冷酷无情，惩罚善良。男女双方都可以自由地发生性关系，但没有一方是完全自由去爱的。听起来挺沮丧的。是的。这很令人心碎。这是我写这本书时最令人悲伤的领悟之一，就是
experiences that are kind, that's something that everyone wants, certainly not just women. So you're right in the book that hook up culture, demands carelessness, rewards callousness, and punishes kindness. Both men and women are free to have sex, but neither is entirely free to love. That sounds pretty depressing. Yeah. It's heartbreaking. It was one of the saddest realizations for me when I was writing the book, just how
乱搞文化已经如此强烈地让学生们确信：他们不应该因为有感觉而感到尴尬，也不应该因为渴望连接而觉得自己软弱。我对这些学生感到非常、非常钦佩。他们真的很聪明。他们很有洞察力。他们是学生。他们真的很聪明。他们很有洞察力。他们很诚恳。他们都是很好的人。但这种文化非常具有毒性。
powerfully hook-up culture has convinced students that they should be embarrassed for having feelings and feel weak for wanting connection. And I am very, very impressed by the students. They're really smart. They're very insightful. They're students. They're really smart. They're very insightful. They're earnest. They're wonderful people. But the culture is very toxic.
丽莎·韦德是西方学院的社会学家，也是《美国乱搞：校园性爱新文化》一书的作者。丽莎，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。这是我的荣幸。本集由蕾妮·克拉克制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括玛吉·彭曼、珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩和克洛伊·康纳利。我们本周的无名英雄是艾伦·费尔丹克雷斯。艾伦是这个播客的忠实听众，直到最近还是美国国家公共电台（NPR）营销团队的成员。
Lisa Wade is a sociologist at Occidental College and the author of the book, American Hookup, the new culture of sex on campus. Lisa, thanks for joining me on Hidden Brain today. It was my pleasure. This episode was produced by Renee Clark and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Maggie Penman, Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen and Chloe Connelly. Our unsung hero this week is Alan Feldancress. Alan's a regular listener to this podcast and until recently was a member of NPR's
艾伦真正理解了《隐藏的大脑》的精髓，他的热情体现在他将新听众与节目联系起来的努力中。他的团队为《隐藏的大脑》设计了一个标志，你可能在社交媒体上或者在NPR礼品店出售的T恤上见过它。非常感谢艾伦，祝你一路顺风。如果《隐藏的大脑》曾是你冒险或公路旅行的一部分，感谢你带上我们。如果你有朋友或家人在2017年踏上旅程，请推荐我们的节目作为他们旅途中的收听材料。
marketing team. Alan really got what Hidden Brain is all about and his enthusiasm came through in his efforts to connect new listeners to the show. His team developed a logo for Hidden Brain, you may have seen it on social media, or on the t-shirts that are available at the NPR gift shop. Many thanks Alan and Bon Voyage. If Hidden Brain has been a part of your adventures or road trips, thank you for bringing us along. If you friends or family embarking on travels in 2017, please suggest our show as listening material
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。
during their journeys. I'm Shankar Vidhantham, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在他们的旅程中。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共广播电台。这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。